l'institut d'éducation motrice de bailly
était festif et aux couleurs américaines
samedi l'association un geste en plus
existe depuis deux ans elle organise des
événements pour récolter des fonds et
financer des projets pour aider le
handicap et son insertion
cette année le projet est axé sur
l'accessibilité pour financer un monte
personne dans une piscine piscine de
saint cyr qui accueille des enfants
handicapés il ya un maître nageur qui
fait des cours pour enfants handicapés
et on aimerait l'aider dans cette
démarche en finançant se lève personne
en arrière
plusieurs associations ont suivi
l'initiative d'un geste en plus
proposant aux enfants en situation de
handicap et leurs parents de s'essayer à
des cours de country et pour les plus
téméraires des baladins moto harley n'y
a pas plus beau qu'un sourire
c'est vrai qu'il faut être honnête ce
sont des enfants avant tout ça nous
touche énormément et de devoirs qu'ils
se sentent bien qu'ils sentent comme
tout le monde qui voit là bon c'est
juste fabuleux quoi c'est la deuxième
fois bgg peu j'ai eu peur au début vous
ai discuté avec mme oda l'association
renouvellera l'événement l'année
prochaine pour récolter encore plus de
sourires
là